ok ich hätte nie gedacht dass ich auf
meinem kanal so weit kommt aber wir
reagieren heute zusammen auf tour
die erdbeeren aus fragt einfach nicht
los geht
wenn ich allein die musik schon höre ich
glaube jeder von euch kennt tom und das
erdbeermarmeladebrot mit honig ist
jemand von euch nicht kennen sollte
hattet ihr überhaupt eine kindheit auf
jeden fall ist mir letztens aufgefallen
dass sie wirklich ihre folge auch auf
youtube veröffentlicht haben und das
heutige video auf das wäre er gern 5
millionen aufrufe eines tages dachte man
ein leckeres erdbeermarmeladebrot mit
honig machte einen spaziergang
dass er also ich meine ich lauf auch
immer so dem blatt doch das
erdbeermarmeladebrot mit honig wollte
ihm nicht mehr aus dem kopf gehen
sie haben wir gegen so einen typen wir
haben ein schwein und wir haben ganz
viel kokain gelagert in einer windmühle
da traf seinen freund den müller
selber nachdenken über einen dummen
fragen
[Musik]
also wenn ich freunde treffe mache ich
auch immer so die begrüßung 2 müller
hast du vielleicht ein erdbeer marmelade
brot mit honig für mich standard
erstmals jemand seinem kollegen sagen
wenn man ihn trifft nicht irgendwie so
ja mal was geht was hast du gemacht am
wochenende die geht seiner freundin
das erste was auch ich fragen würde wäre
hast du vielleicht ein held marmelade
brot mit honig für mich aber eine
scheibe brot kann ich dir schenkt und
eine erdbeere bekommst du sicher bei der
erdwärme aus weil die nämlich ein
riesiges erdbeerfeld gesetzt
wir kämpfen nicht erst per maus mit
ihrem riesigen erdbeerfeld tom hielt das
für eine wunderbare idee der müller gab
ihm seine scheibe brot die beiden
verabschiedete sich und machte sich auf
den weg zur erdwärme müsste er nicht
eigentlich den kompletten berg so
runterrutschen wieder da läuft also er
läuft jetzt zur märz per maus mit seinem
brot vom müller er denkt an eine
erdbeere
nee das ist die maus sie daran denken
sie jetzt bei der maus angekommen kann
ich mir aus kannst du mir vielleicht
eine deiner köstlichen erdbeeren
schenken
die kann er noch sprechen die apple maus
oder wasser und erde sei also die szene
beschreibt ja irgendwie das komplette
video wird er doch mal eine scheibe brot
von seinem ehren brudermüller bekommen
und die erdbeeren aus wie du mir jetzt
keine erdbeere geben und jagt ihnen auf
einem krokodil
also ich weiß nicht wie ich das als kind
so gefeiert haben jetzt einfach weg und
verzichtet auf einem baum
das krokodil beschwert jetzt auge oder
was pflanzen doch deine eigene lb
experte sammeln und wenn es mir gelingt
eine erdbeere wachsen zu lassen
dann darf ich deine erdweg wetschen
benutzen ok warum hat sie sich der jetzt
auf die hand des spuckt ist abgemacht
gespuckt ist abgemacht leute wenn ihr
abonnent seit von meinem kanal dann
schreibt jetzt mal in die kommentare
das buch ist abgemacht natürlich hat das
krokodil in seinem bauch eine schale
erdbeeren und schweizer im morgengrauen
war dann tatsächlich eine erdbeere
gewachsen vergleicht mal die größe der
der erdbeere mit der größe von tom sonne
große er wäre hätte ich auch eher an und
jetzt will ich deine quetschen benutzen
und jetzt wird sich die erdbeere genau
ich bin international anerkannte airbag
venture das krokodil ist ein
international anerkannter erdberg
venture das etwas einzigartiges und
deswegen klatsche ich die erdbeeren und
mit einem satz klatschte das krokodil
die arge zu mama wenn du mir jetzt etwas
honig obst dann schenke ich dir die
restliche marmelade kommt die hohe nicht
nicht von dieser linie die da immer
drauf scheißt okay das buch der stadt
gemacht
es hat eine gespuckt ist abgemacht ist
selbst neues ding oder was ja ja ja da
honig in seiner bauchtasche ohne erstmal
ein paar seite aus machen
ja toll freut sich über eine milliarde
brot und das krokodil zeigt daumen hoch
und die maus zeigt das doch dumm ist er
verbrachte noch den garten optimieren
gefällt wunschlos glücklich und bespuckt
ist abgemacht
[Musik]